salut romain ça va ouais ça va ai dit tu
connais le col de l'utérus
bah oui enfin le pourquoi c ou c dans
les alpes non non non non c'est pas la
non écoute tu envoies de génériques et
on en parle juste après ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous en avez sûrement entendu parler
pour différentes raisons aujourd'hui on
va faire le tour de la question enfin
des questions qui se posent au sujet du
vaccin contre le cancer du col de
l'utérus et on va commencer tout de
suite ça n'est pas un vaccin contre le
cancer
parce que ça ça n'existe pas mais fait
effectivement un vaccin qui permet
d'éviter le cancer du col de l'utérus
mais pas seulement c'est déjà compliqué
hein
sauf que non en fait c'est plutôt simple
le vaccin contre le hpv human papilloma
virus y protège contre certains types de
papillomavirus le papillomavirus
c'est un virus il annonce clairement la
couleur avec son nom et lui son truc
c'est de fabriquer des verrues alors ils
fabriquent des verrues plantaires
conçoit pas la piscine des verrues sur
les mains des verrues sur le visage
et puis y en a certains qui donne des
verrues génitales qu'on appelle des
condylomes ou des végétations
vénériennes dit comme ça c'est joli mais
en fait non très peu vous les connaissez
peut-être aussi sous le nom de crête de
coq et là tout de suite ça donne moins
envie d'avoir un truc qui fait cocorico
en slip alors rassurez vous ça ressemble
pas des crêtes de coq tout de suite au
début c'est vraiment juste comme des
petites verrues
le mieux c'est de s'en occuper avant
d'en arriver à la phase basse cour
le mieux c'est surtout ne pas en avoir
et c'est bien le sujet du jour parce
qu'il se trouve que le papillomavirus il
se contente pas de fabriquer des verrues
génitales
il en a aussi certains qui crée d'autres
types de lésions qui peuvent dégénérer
en cancer
on appelle ça des lésions précancéreuses
et elles peuvent se situer au niveau du
col de l'utérus mais aussi de la vulve
et du vagin de l'anus ou de la gorge
donc mais vous avez compris si vous
savez lire entre les lignes on est en
train de parler d'une infection
sexuellement transmissible à
papillomavirus et sachez que c'est la
première cause de cancer du col de
l'utérus
du coup le vaccin qui protège contre le
virus donc contre la cause la plus
fréquente du cancer
comme ça c'est plus clair alors vous
allez me dire ok mais bon contre les
infections sexuellement transmissibles
on a déjà un truc qui marche bien le
préservatif et vous avez raison c'est
indispensable mais dans le cas qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui il faut savoir que
les condylomes sont très contagieux et
qu'on peut les attraper par simple
contact contact avec une partie non
couverte par le préservatif par exemple
ou avant de mettre le préservatif genre
avec la bouche les mains voyez où je
veux en venir
donc le préservatif oui évidemment
mais c'est pas une assurance tous
risques en ce qui concerne le
papillomavirus
alors ok mais le vaccin comment ça
marche bon déjà le principe de ce vaccin
c'est qu'on vous injecte une petite dose
du virus inactivé c'est à dire qui peut
pas vous rendre malade
c'est juste pour que votre organisme le
reconnaissent et après se défendre quand
il rencontre un vrai c'est un peu comme
prendre des cours de self défense contre
à un mannequin en mousse pour que le
vaccin soit vraiment efficace il faut
qu'il soit fait avant que vous n'ayez
été en contact avec le virus
c'est-à-dire avant le début de la vie
sexuelle ou dans l'année qui suivent
premier rapport le principe d'un maxence
et faire de la prévention est par
définition la prévention ça se fait
avant le risque existe
il ya plusieurs sortes de vaccin qui
protège contre différents types de
papillomavirus et ça se fait en deux ou
trois injections le vaccin ne fait pas
partie des onze vaccin obligatoire mais
il est recommandé pour toutes les jeunes
filles entre 11 et 14 ans il ya même une
cession possible de rattrapage entre 15
et 19 ans petit truc au passage le
vaccin ça empêche évidemment pas d'avoir
un suivi gynécologique régulier pour le
dépistage évidemment mais aussi pour
tout le reste dans certains pays on
recommande de vacciner aussi les garçons
en france jusqu'ici c'était seulement
recommandée pour les garçons qui ont des
rapports homosexuels par rapport au
cancer de la gorge et de l'anus le
projet d'appliquer aux garçons les mêmes
recommandations koffi c'était à l'étude
fin 2019
et bah ça y est c'est fait en 2020 la
vaccination va être étendu aux garçons
en france parce que oui statistiquement
les femmes sont plus concernés par les
le cancer mais les cancer du pénis ça
existe aussi
et parce que la couverture vaccinale
elle n'est pas suffisante aujourd'hui et
ça permettra de limiter la contamination
quand les hommes seront vaccinés aussi
et puis au fond comme ça on donne les
mêmes chances à tout le monde pour être
complet sur le sujet il faut que je vous
dise que les verrues génitales
ça se soigne parfois ça disparaît tout
seul parfois même avant qu'on se rende
compte qu'on en a ce qui augmente le
risque de contaminer son partenaire mais
parfois ça se voit ça veut pas partir et
il faut prendre des traitements
il ya des traitements qui stimule le
système immunitaire pour se débarrasser
du virus
et puis il ya des pommades des lotions à
appliquer sur les lésions
ça pique un petit peu et il ya le là
vers l'électro coagulation ou l'azoté
liquide
et comme pour les autres verrue sauf que
bon voilà c'est pas à placer au même
endroit je vous laisse imaginer
en plus c'est pas toujours très
accessible et puis tout ça ça fait
disparaître les condylomes mais pas le
virus du coup il a tendance à revenir et
puis surtout il ya les lésions
précancéreuses et c'est là selon le
stade auquel on les découvre soit on
utilise à peu près les mêmes techniques
soit il faut opérer et retirer la partie
qui est atteinte
on estime que 80 % des personnes qui ont
une vie sexuelle seront en contact un
jour ou l'autre avec le papillomavirus
donc le mieux c'est de prévenir plutôt
que de guérir mais alors je sais les
vaccins ça fait peur surtout qu'on
entend dire tout un tas de trucs dessus
donc on va faire un peu le tour dans
différents pays il ya des personnes qui
avaient été vaccinés qui ont déclaré des
maladies a les mêmes suivant les pays et
qui les ont attribuées aux vaccins en
france il ya des plaintes qui ont été
déposées pour des quatre clés rose en
plaques ou d'autres maladies auto
immunes
dans tous les cas de figure les études
qui ont été menées ont amené les agences
française et européenne du médicament et
l'organisation mondiale de la santé oms
même conclusion rien n'a permis de
mettre en évidence que la cause des
maladies
vaccins par et le nombre de cas de ces
maladies et pas plus important chez les
jeunes femmes vaccinées que chez les
jeunes femmes non vaccinés et les
plaintes déposées en france ont été
déclaré sans suite
après toutes ces études les effets
indésirables les plus fréquents qui ont
été attribués aux vaccins sont des
rougeurs des douleurs et un gonflement
au point d'injection et des maux de tête
d'autres effets comme des nausées des
douleurs musculaires des difficultés
respiratoires ou des réactions
allergiques ont aussi été recensés et il
a été précisé que d atteinte du système
nerveux comme le syndrome de
guillain-barré ont été
exceptionnellement observé alors sur ce
dernier point il ya certaines études qui
ont estimé que le risque de développer
syndrome était pas augmenter avec le
vaccin
et il y en a d'autres qui ont conclu que
ce risque était inférieure à 1 sur 1
million ce qui a permis de conclure que
la balance bénéfice risque était en
faveur du vaccin
c'est à dire que le risque de développer
un effet indésirable par rapport aux
bénéfices d'éviter un concert c'était
fini pour vous faire une idée avec
quelques chiffres dans certains pays
comme l'australie par exemple où 80% des
personnes concernées sont vaccinés le
nombre de lésions précancéreuses du col
de l'utérus donc l'étape avant le cancer
a diminué de façon spectaculaire et en
suède cas les mêmes taux de vaccination
elles ont diminué de 75 % chez les
jeunes filles vaccinées en france on est
à 20 % de personnes concernées et
vaccinés et chaque année 3000 nouveaux
cas de cancer du col de l'utérus sont
déclarés pour 1100 décès si vous vous
posez des questions pour vous même ou
pour vos enfants
je vous mets des liens dans la
description de la vidéo mais surtout
n'hésitez pas à en parler à vos parents
à votre médecin ou en appelant un des
numéros d'information anonyme et gratuit
là encore je vous mets un lien dans la
description voit la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos
d'ici là protégez-vous et protéger les
autres prenez soin de vous et prenez
soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]